hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the henderson
gambit which is
a pretty wild variation in not only the
king's gambit but the fog bear counter
gambit
i've gotten a few requests on this
opening i'm not exactly sure
why from white's perspective i'm not
sure it's the best
way to attack the fog beer counter
gambit
but i thought i would go and do the
video one is the king's gambit if anyone
has a request in the kings game and i
try to make those videos for sure but
also from black's perspective it's
always good to know
if your opponent's doing something weird
and outside the norm
how should you attack that so i know a
lot of people really enjoy the falkbar
county game
so i thought this would be good to go
over because you may see it from time to
time
so the king's gamut the best opening in
chess starts out with pawnee four
e5 and then pawn to f4 and the
falcore counter game it continues with
d5
says i'm just gonna counter attack the
center of the board here
now usually white's gonna be playing
knight to f3
because that really stops the threat of
the queen coming down here to
h4 but the henderson game it says
what if we just go wild in the center
and play pawn
to d4 and so this is the opening that
we're going to be going over today
there's four variations we're going to
look at
we're going to look at this pawn here on
e5 takes either
the pawn here on f4 or here on d4
we are going to look at this pawn on d5
taking on e4
and lastly we're going to look at the
knight coming here to
f6 more than like i think they're going
to take one of these central pawns but
they definitely could play
knight to f6 there's some interesting
lines that if you were playing as black
that you could
go down so let's dive into the first
version that is the pawn taking here on
f4 and this sets up for the immediate
threat of queen to h4
check now you can't do that right away
because queen down to h4 and they just
play pawn g3 this stops our threat right
away
queen has to move back here but after
the pawn takes on f4 there's an
immediate threat down here on h4
that white has to deal with now from
white's perspective
if you run this like a computer engine
one the computer is going to be very
confused that you're playing
the henderson gambit it doesn't have a
lot of theory on it and so it's going to
recommend
some ridiculous moves like pawn takes
here on d5
i think that's a terrible move
absolutely don't play that as white
because then you're just gonna have to
deal with queen down two h4 and how do
you really deal with this okay pawn to
g3
doesn't make a lot of sense because pawn
takes here the next move is going to be
pawn 2 g2
discovered attack and then you're going
to lose the rook here on h1
okay so maybe you play bishop 2g2 to
stop that but then they just take the
pawn here on h2
check king all things bad it's not going
very well but the only other option
instead of g3 is you play king 2 d2
knight to f6 this king is blocking your
dark square bishop which usually wants
to come out take this pawn here on
f4 this pawn here on d5 is going to fall
the dark square bishop getting involved
into the game and it's it's all just bad
just don't do this at all so really the
option you should be looking at if
you're white's perspective
is you need to be playing bishop takes
here on f4 this
stops the threat of the queen coming
down here at h4 because then yeah you
just play pawn to g3
you still have this structure here you
are blowing up your king side of the
board you can always cast on the queen
side if you wanted to
but then black is gonna be forced to
retreat in this spot so
after the bishop takes here on f4
black's typically gonna just take here
on e4 i think black has a pretty good
setup but i think this is the best white
can get out of this position
usually if you give up your f pawn in
the king's gambit you typically want to
have your e-pawn
if you don't have either of these pawns
it's going to be very difficult to hold
on
for a really strong game but play may
continue knight to c3 attack in the pawn
knight to f6 as you typically see as
both knights really attacking
the pawn and defending the pawn bishop
here to c4
you have to stay pretty aggressive here
bishop d7 preparing to castle on the
king side
knight to e2 can't come to knight to f3
where it normally would want to come to
because of the pawn here so maybe knight
to e2 castle on the king side
castle and you can see black is up upon
the material i think it's going to be
difficult for white but again they don't
have too many good options
this is not the best opening from
white's perspective but you can see
it's not too difficult for black to come
up with a very good game plan
against this gambit the next version
we're going to look at is if the pawn
on e5 now takes the d4 pawn white's
usually going to respond the queen takes
on d4
both of the bishops from white can
easily get involved into the game now
they have a central queen that can be
very very difficult to deal with we're
going to look at two variations
one is the pawn taking here on e4
for black now white needs to be cautious
not to go ahead and train queens because
after the king takes
maybe knight to c3 attacking the pawn
knight to f6 defending the pawn
you can see bishop c4 the king comes
back over here to e8
black is up upon a material and usually
from white's perspective
and the king's gambit you go down upon a
material but you still have your
powerful piece in the queen
and then you launch a pretty big attack
and then hopefully you have the
advantage
you're chasing your opponent's king
around you have your queen you have a
strong attack
white does not have that here white's
just down a pawn in material
and there's no clear path to go ahead
and get that back so
this is not the best approach for white
now that does not mean that this is the
correct play for black i think there's a
better option for black that you can put
your opponent
in a tougher spot because if white plays
it correctly
they could just go ahead and take the
pawn here on e4
now both sides have no central pawns
which is kind of a weird setup in chess
but then maybe bishop to e7 knight here
to c3
knight to f6 here attacking the queen
queen can come back
if black wants to trade they absolutely
can knight to c6
just definitely don't think this is the
best approach that black can take
instead of taking this pawn here on e4
what i really like is the move knight to
f6 because
it's really baiting your opponent this
just sets up so easy
for them to play the move e5 it attacks
the knight here on f6
okay great and they have a little pawn
chain going right here so this is almost
an immediate move that you might see
here
and black has the really good move
knight to e4
this is a great outpost this knight here
on e4
can't be moved by a pawn on either the d
or the f-file
d-pawn is gone and the f-pawn here on f4
has already passed
and so how does white really continue
here they can put themselves in a
pretty tough spot in this position it's
one example they may play bishop here to
d3 and say okay
i have to get this out of the way so
let's go ahead and play bishop d3
attacking this knight but that loses to
bishop
to c5 now if you start to look at the
moves that the queen can go to it can't
retreat back on this d
file it can't come down this dark square
diagonal
just lose to the bishop here can't take
the bishop that's protected by the
knight here the only safe square is
queen over here to a four
check bishop to d7
attacking the queen queen falls back
here but then the devastating move queen
2 h4 check and you can see pawn
g3 knight takes here on g3
if the pawn takes queen takes here on h1
but then how does white really continue
in this spot
you can see the light square bishop
getting bombed to the game if it needs
to this dark square bishop is still
attacking all these dark squares here
so this is going to be a pretty tough
spot now if we look from blacks
or from white standpoint what are the
other options uh to continue sometimes
if there's an outpost you always want to
attack that pawn so
maybe pawn to c4 but same thing bishop
here to
c5 attacking this queen queen's in a
pretty tough spot here now they
they in this spot they can take maybe
this pawn here
but then after the queen takes here on
d5 the pawn takes
now knight down to f2 this is defended
by the bishop here on c5
and this rook here on h1 is going to
fall
so again white fell for the trap and
it's just so difficult to see
all the threats that black really has
another option would be
instead of playing pawn to c4 they could
play knight to
f3 same thing as before bishop to
c5 maybe queen a4
pawn c6 stopping the threat right there
bishop to d3 maybe makes more sense from
white standpoint to try to get this
knight which is a really good outpost
away but then
pawn down to b5 attacking the queen
queen
b3 bishop here to e6 preparing for a
discovered attack with a d4
or if there's ever a capture here on e4
as well
that would also be a discovered attack
on the queen here so lots of good
options
from black if they decide to allow us to
have this knight here on e4
the next variation we're going to be
looking at is if this d-pawn
takes on e4 extremely uncommon
but hey thought we'd go over it just
because you may see some crazy stuff
if you're already playing this gambit
now usually from white's perspective
they're looking to give up the pawn here
on f4
they usually don't get the chance to
take back a material and have two
central pawns to their opponent's one
central pawn so
they're probably just going to snap take
here on e5
and the only way that black can really
continue here they can't play knight to
f6
because it's being stopped by the pawn
here on e5
they don't want to play knight to e7
knight to h6
and then after bishop two c4 bishop down
here to g4 and this knight protects it
here but if your play really is to play
knight to h6 and bishop down to g4 i
think there's just so many better
options for black here hopefully if
you're facing this as black you've
chosen
a different option that we already went
over here but from here
you may see knight to e2 blocking the
attack on the queen here
knight to c6 attacking this pawn here on
d4 now maybe pawn to c3 stopping that or
just say you know what we don't even
care about that maybe knight to c3
because it doesn't matter too much this
this knight here on
e2 can't really defend this pawn on d4
because it is being pinned down by the
bishop here on
g4 so maybe queen to h4 check
pawn g3 queen comes back here doubling
up the attack on this light square
diagonal here
who knows exactly how play could
continue or could just castle so
uh instead of pawn three pawn to c3 or
knight to c3 just cast on the king side
maybe the bishop takes queen takes here
queen comes down
takes pawn here on d4 check uh so
a lot of variations that you could come
down not a lot of theory in this
particular variation
don't think you'll see it too much
instead of that elastic change with the
pawn you
could actually see the knight taking
here or the knight just coming down to
f6 it's a pretty interesting idea here
and it all stems from the thought of
yeah after the pawn takes on e5
really want to get that outpost here on
e4 now it's not as good as the setup as
we saw before but still
very difficult for white to deal with uh
and so how do they deal with it now they
could just play
knight to f3 okay well we see
c5 attacking this pawn here
on d4 maybe bishop to
uh d3 attacking the knight a little bit
better now the queen's not trapped as it
was here on d4 and the bishop comes down
to c5 as we saw before so maybe knight
to c6
bishop takes pawn takes attacking this
knight here on a g5
and then the pawn takes and this you
know puts a lot of pressure on
on white here now the knight can come
take here on
e4 things get pretty complicated from
here you can see queen down to
a d5 preparing to get the bishops
involved into the game attacking this
knight right here
how does white really continue to defend
this one idea is to play knight to d2
can't come to c3 that's being defended
by this square here on d4 so maybe
knight to d2
but then knight takes here on d5 and you
can see this dark square bishop is
blocked off for white
don't think it's a pretty good setup at
all another option is say
okay we don't want to block off this
bishop let's go and play queen to
f3 here but then just bishop to e6
maybe bishop out here to f4 getting it
outside
now the night if it wants to come to d2
it can
but then the knight can still take here
even if the bishop takes queen takes
here
casts on the king side and white's going
to have a better position whites up a
pawn in a material it has the bishop
pair here
and i think going into an open ended
in game black's just gonna have a much
better game so that is
the very interesting henderson gambit in
the king's gamut foxbear counter gambit
variations
from white's perspective again i think
there's better options
if you're just having fun which i think
chess should be you can definitely try
that about from black's perspective
i think you definitely have some good
options to attack your opponent
if they are going to try this hopefully
this was helpful
entertaining for those who had maybe not
heard of it before
or seen it but if you have played it let
me know what your thoughts are if
there's any other openings
or any other videos you'd like me to do
let me know in the comments below always
looking
for requests looking to add some to
the wish list that i'll be making over
the next
few weeks and months but thank you guys
so much for watching the video i'll see
you guys next time
you